la même une rivière pour rêver
sur ses bords une falaise digne de
porter un château une enceinte de tours
à rendre jaloux le roi de france qui les
fit raser au niveau d'un famille
dans le silence de cet espace protégé
dans cet écrin imposant repose un joyau
comme bell au château dormant une
tapisserie mieux une tenture la plus
ancienne que l'on connaisse la plus
vaste qui fut jamais tisser elle fut
commandée par louis premier d'anjou
omettre lissiers parisien nicolas
bataille il ya maintenant six siècles
c'est la tapisserie de l'apocalypse
il naît homme qui puisse écrire ni
raconter la valeur la beauté la noblesse
de cette issue ainsi parlait un
bourgeois d'armes au temps où elle
décorer les murs de l'archevêché de sa
ville à l'origine 168 mètres de long sur
5 mètres de large
elle a été composée de cette grande
pièce en deux bandes superposées de sept
tableaux car le nombre 7 est le symbole
de la perfection le bon roi rené fido de
son beau tapis au chanoine de la
cathédrale d'angers et jusqu'à la
révolution
il figurera dans toutes les cérémonies
religieuses mais des temps nouveaux sont
arrivés et des modes nouvelle ces
vieilleries sont dispersés disloqué
jusqu'à ce qu'un évêque est l'heureuse
idée de racheter ce qui en reste
les trois quarts environ pour 300 francs
c'était en 1843
l'apocalypse
dème chère au créateur du moyen-âge qui
ont aimé évoqué la grande voie mystique
qui annonce par delà les conflits par
delà le duel du bien et du mal la
victoire finale des baux la victoire des
jours heureux sur les mauvais jours et
la naissance d'un monde nouveau
l'apocalyse une vision pour tout le
temps en se jetant la pierre était mort
exécuté paul était mort exécuté comme
jésus-christ jésus-christ dont on avait
annoncé le retour imminent tardait à
revenir les persécutions comment ces
gens l'apôtre jusqu alors silencieux
avait compris que l'église désormais
devait affronter le temps la durée
qu'elles devaient affronter aussi les
dangers et les ennemis de toute sorte
alors il lança comme un grand cri
d'espérance
le cri de la victoire au delà de toutes
les batailles
le cri de la victoire au delà de la mort
le cri de l'apocalypse
moi j'en je fus ravi en esprit le jour
du seigneur et j'entendis une voix forte
qui disait ce que tu vois écrit le dans
le livre et envoie le haut cette église
alors je vis le fils de l'homme ça bouge
porté le glaive de la justice
je tombais à ses pieds comme mort il
posa sa main droite sur moi ne crains
rien je suis le premier et le dernier le
vivant je serai vivant pour les siècles
des siècles et je détiens les clés de la
mort et de l'enfer
une porte était ouverte dans le ciel je
vis sièges sur un trône quelqu'un 24
vieillard l'adorait
lui tenait un livre dans sa main mais le
livre est fermée seller de sept saulx
qui sera digne d'ouvrir le livre seul
l'agneau en est digne parce qu'il a été
égorgé et qu'il a racheté pour dieu par
son sens des hommes de toute tribu
langue peuple ou nation
quand l'agneau rompit le premier show je
vis paraître un cheval blanc celui qui
le montait avait la couronne et l'arc de
la puissance et je lui paraître un
cheval noir celui qui le montait portait
à la main
la balance de la famille
puis un cheval de couleurs vives et
celui qui le montait s'appelait monde et
pouvoir le fusionner de faire périr un
quart de la terre
et je vis l'hôtel les âmes des martyrs
qui réclamaient leur jugement et leur
vengeance
alors il se fit un grand tremblement de
terre au cours périr ils ne furent
épargnés que ceux qui étaient marqués au
front du signe de dieu 144000 de toutes
les tribus d'israël de la tribu de juda
12 me de la tribu de rubin 12 mire de la
tribu de gad 12 mire de la tribu d'âge
air 12012 mire 12000 12012 nuits et kans
l'agneau huron pull le septième sceau je
vis cet ange qui se tenait devant dieu
et on leur donne à cette trompette le
premier range sonna de la trompette il
eu de la grêle et du feu mais les deux
sens et le tiers de la mère de 20 du
sang et le tir des créatures qui avait
souffle dans la mer
perry et le tiers des navires fut
détruit
une grande étoile tomba du ciel sur les
fleuves et les sources et beaucoup
d'hommes moururent parce que les eaux
avaient ainsi été rendu amer et fut
frappé le tiers du soleil le tiers de la
lune et le tiers des étoiles
et le puits de la bible chute ouvert il
en sortit des sauterelles qui se
répandirent partout
et furent délivrés les quatre anges qui
se tenait prêt pour l'heure le jour le
mois et l'année fixé pour exterminer le
tiers des hommes à la 7è trompette
éclata le champ des 24 dégâts nous te
rendons grâce parce que tu as prise en
main à grande puissance et que tu as
établie oreilles alors comment ça le
prend combat de la femme et du dragon
bataille dans le ciel bataille sur la
terre
je vise une bête qui montait de la mer
elle avait sur la tête des noms
blasphématoire
le dragon lui ai remis sa puissance son
trône et un grand pouvoir
la foule se prosterna devant le dragon
parce qu'il avait donné pouvoir à la
bête la foule se prosternant devant la
bête à qui fut donnée de faire la guerre
au sein et de l'es20 alors je vis
l'agneau qui se tenait debout sur la
montagne de sion accompagné de son 44
mille fidèles qui portait son nom et le
nom de son père sur leur front
je vise un ange qui valait au milieu du
chêne il disait d'une voix puissante
elle est tombée elle est tombée babylone
la grande elle qui abreuver les nations
du vin de la colère de sa fornication
j'entendis d'une voix dans le ciel
heureux plutôt ceux qui s'endorment dans
la paix du seigneur un autre ange
proclamait et si quelqu'un adore la bête
et son image lui aussi boira du vin de
la colère de dieu
alors bis border les 7 coupes de la
colère de dieu
un ulcère mauvais et pernicieux
atteignit les hommes qui portaient la
marque de la bête et adorait son image
tout être vivant qui était dans la mère
mourut les sources des os de verre du
sang il fut donné au soleil du brûlé les
hommes par son feu
le royaume de la bête fut envahie de tes
nerfs et le grand fleuve de l'euphrate
fut taries pour que fut préparé la route
des barbares qui venait d'orient
et ce furent des éclairs des clameurs
des tonnerres il eut à tremblement de
terre comme il ne s'en était encore
jamais produit une voix forte criard
elle est tombée babylone la grande elle
est devenue la teneur des démons un pur
car toutes les nations vue du vin de sa
furieuse prostitution et les rois de la
terre on forniquer avec l'aele et les
marchands se sont enrichis du
débordement de son luxe c'est péché se
sont accumulés jusqu'au ciel et le
seigneur s'est souvenu de ces iniquités
hellange midi écrit heureux les invités
au repas de noces de l'agneau
alors je vis le ciel ouvert et sur le
cheval blanc le cavalier de gloire la
bête fut prise et avec elle ce qu'ils
avaient adoré son image touche furent
jetés vivants dans les temps de feu tout
prix en dessous
moi j'en je vis la cité sainte la
jérusalem nouvelle elle descendait du ch
elle doperait de dieu belle comme la
jeune épouse par et pour l'amour
l'ange me fit voir le fleuve de vie
éternelle vient que l'homme a soif et
s'approche et qu'il boit car voici que
je fais toutes choses nouvelles